Trascrizione: Claudia Di Lorenzo
Revisore: Isabelle Andrieu
Care amiche e cari amici,
arriva da Ferrandina,
in provincia di Matera,
la storia che sto per raccontarvi.
È la storia del Bibliomotocarro,
una piccola biblioteca viaggiante
a forma di casetta con tanto
di tegole rosse e comignolo fumante,
che suscita subito, immediatamente,
piacevolezza e simpatia.
Appena mi incontrano lungo le strade,
ognuno sorride.
Il sorriso è il biglietto da visita.
Ma, oltre alla piacevolezza,
suscita anche accoglienza,
e direi accessibilità.
Il Bibliomotocarro,
con il progetto "Fino
ai margini, oltre il confine"
svolge attività di promozione del libro,
della lettura e della scrittura
nei paesi piccoli e piccolissimi
della Basilicata.
Porta cioè i libri
dove ce n'è più bisogno.
Senza negare a ciascun bambino
il diritto di avere tra le mani
il libro che desidera.
E lo fa con straordinaria semplicità.
"I libri hanno messo le ruote",
così si chiama il servizio
di biblioteca viaggiante
con prestito gratuito dei libri,
che ha una particolarità:
non ha il registro dei prestiti.
Il Bibliomotocarro semina fiducia
con la consapevolezza, però,
che dietra questa semina di fiducia,
giorno dopo giorno,
chilometro dopo chilometro,
avete sentito, vent'anni,
200.000 chilometri,
produce un raccolto di responsabilità.
Il Bibliomotocarro ha avuto negli anni,
nacque nel 1999,
ha avuto negli anni la capacità
di sapersi innovare rimanendo sé stesso.
Il mezzo è sempre quello.
Un mezzo umile, semplice, povero, lento.
Però, alla prima attività
"I libri hanno messo le ruote"
aggiunse i "Libri Bianchi".
Prima che io vi dica
che cosa sono i "Libri Bianchi",
mi piace raccontarvi una storia:
ero a San Mauro Forte,
un comune della collina materana,
e stavamo facendo l'attività
"I libri hanno messo le ruote".
Fanciulli della scuola
secondaria di primo grado
stavano scegliendo il libro
che avrebbero tenuto per un mese.
Il Bibliomotocarro di solito
torna a scadenza di un mese.
Ad un certo punto,
una fanciullina bulgara,
Adalina,
timidamente, da dietro,
con un filo di voce mi disse:
"Maestro, e se i libri
li scrivessimo noi?".
Una espressione di una tale forza!
"Maestro, e se i libri
li scrivessimo noi?"
Era una richiesta di raccontarsi,
di raccontare la sua storia,
quando la mamma comunicò
che avrebbero lasciato il loro paese,
che sarebbero venuti in Italia,
in Basilicata, in provincia di Matera,
a San Mauro Forte.
"Che bella cosa, Adalina, ci pensiamo."
In realtà io non ci pensai
affatto, andai a Matera,
acquistai 200 volumetti
di 80 pagine bianche
con la copertina rossa, verde e azzurra
che potesse dare l'idea del libro
e li diffusi per tutti i paesi
della Basilicata.
Per offrire la possibilità
di raccontare e di raccontarsi.
Che cosa sono i "Libri Bianchi"?
Sono libri composti da racconti
scritti da bambini di paesi diversi.
Una storia comincia in un posto,
poi quella storia continua in un altro
e poi in un altro ancora.
Storie che si intrecciano.
Un laboratorio itinerante di scrittura,
ma soprattutto una straordinaria
opportunità per il mondo
della fanciullezza di raccontare
e di raccontarsi,
e ce n'è tanto bisogno.
E poi, il Cinema Letterario.
Entrare con la testa,
uscire con gli occhi.
Ieri sono stato al rione Isola
e poi alla biblioteca La Chiesa Rossa
e quando i bambi
di questi quartieri periferici
sono entrati nella casetta
che è in realtà un cinema itinerante,
e han visto i cortometraggi di animazione,
fatti da bambini su testi letterari.
Io leggevo la poesia,
la filastrocca, poi dicevo,
"Bambini, andiamo
al cinema!". "Al cinema?".
Io aprivo gli sportelloni posteriori,
entravano e si accendeva questo cinema.
"Dalla pagina al mondo",
un altro laboratorio.
Si parte da una pagina di letteratura
e i fanciulli scrivono altre storie.
Queste storie poi si intrecciano,
diventano una storia unica,
una sceneggiatura.
I fanciulli diventano interpreti
di una storia che loro
stessi hanno scritto
partendo da una bella pagina
di letteratura.
Il Bibliomotocarro nacque a scuola.
Quarantadue anni di maestro elementare:
io facendo il maestro,
parlo di 25 anni fa,
coglievo ogni giorno
questa crescente disaffezione
nei confronti del libro.
Questo progressivo affievolimento
del rapporto tra libri
e mondo della fanciullezza.
"Bambini, c'è un problema,
bisogna fare qualcosa!"
"Maestro, fallo tu questo qualcosa."
E dicendo questo,
gettavano un seme dentro di me.
E che cosa trovava questo seme?
Trovava una candela.
Cari amici,
i miei genitori erano contadini.
E quando mia madre
spegneva la lampadina di casa...
La lampadina di casa -
a casa mia c'era una sola lampadina -
io, che allora, otto anni, nove anni,
quindi parlo di 65 anni fa,
mi stavo appassionando
al piacere di leggere,
alla gioia di leggere.
Per poterlo fare, accendevo una candela.
Quella candela non si è
mai spenta dentro di me.
È ancora accesa,
e alimenta la passione che mi porta
a percorrere 200. 000 chilometri.
"Maestro, perché lo fai?"
"Perché mi piace",
è la risposta che spesso do
ad increduli che sentono
che sono partito alle quattro di mattina.
Che si chiedono, "Perché lo fai?"
Torniamo a scuola.
Perché la scuola,
care amiche e cari amici...
Nella vecchia, cara scuola elementare
accadevano delle cose straordinarie.
Che cosa è accaduto a me?
Che i bambini che nel frattempo
erano diventati fanciulli
erano passati dalla seconda
alla terza alla quarta.
Quando ho sentito dire,
"Maestro, qui c'è un problema!
I libri si stanno allontanando."
Non mi hanno detto più,
"Puoi farlo tu questa cosa", no.
"Maestro, la devi fare tu questa cosa."
Cogliendo un elemento fondamentale,
perché sarebbe stata bella questa cosa
se l'avesse fatto un architetto,
un ingegnere, un commerciante, un operaio.
No, ma se a farla fosse stato un maestro?
Sarebbe stata bellissima.
Hanno avuto ragione loro, come sempre.
Loro, i bambini.
Quindi dovevo fare qualcosa.
"La devi fare tu questa cosa."
Si trattava di capire cosa.
E allora bastava richiamare l'attenzione
su quel problema che stava emergendo,
bastava lanciare un grido d'allarme:
"Ma che stiamo facendo?"
Ma possiamo fare a meno
dei libri? No, non bastava.
L'iniziativa doveva avere dentro di sé
una possibile soluzione,
e la soluzione non poteva
che essere quella,
mettere le ruote ai libri.
Scomodarli.
E le ruote dovevano essere tre,
quelle di un mezzo più umile,
più semplice, più povero,
ribadisco, più lento.
Un'idea rivoluzionaria.
Da sempre i libri sono stati in alto,
simbolo ed espressione
di una cultura aristocratica,
elitaria, per pochi e di pochi.
Bisognava allargare,
bisogna allargare la base democratica,
bisogna andare alla ricerca
di nuovi lettori con un mezzo accessibile.
Il motocarro, dalle nostre parti,
è il mezzo che porta
la frutta, la verdura,
all'angolo della strada, sotto casa,
e i bambini corrono.
Ecco, la stessa cosa
succede con il Bibliomotocarro
e sanno che trovano i libri,
non trovano pop-corn o gelati.
Eppure corrono.
Ecco, accessibile,
un mezzo che potesse
e che possa consentire
questo allargamento
della base democratica.
È stato facile? No.
Ho trovato ostacoli.
Vi racconto una storia
che vi sembrerà una favola.
Ha i contorni di una favola
ma è una storia vera.
I primi anni,
il Bibliomotocarro non riusciva a superare
i 30, 35 chilometri orari.
Sulle grandi strade
che costeggiano i fiumi.
La Basentana, la Val d'Agri,
la Sinnica, la Bradanica.
Non mi sapevo spiegare perché.
Certo, il Bibliomotocarro è pesante,
dieci quintali, ma c'era qualcos'altro.
E lo scoprii che c'era qualcos'altro.
Era il disappunto,
la contrarietà dei libri
che non avevano gradito
quello che io avevo fatto,
di averli scomodati.
"Ma chi si crede di essere?
Cosa pensa di fare questo maestro?
Noi eravamo su scaffali alti e nobili",
diceva un libro all'alto libro.
"Questi ci hanno messo
su scaffali modesti,
di un modesto e umile motocarro
e ci porta in giro per le strade.
Noi siamo i libri."
E quando io captai questo,
dissi, "È fatta, la partita è vinta,
perché sapevo che avrebbero cambiato idea,
altrimenti non sarebbero stati
i capolavori della
letteratura per ragazzi.
Infatti, dopo qualche tempo,
cominciai a sentire Capitani Coraggiosi
che diceva, "Eh, che poi...
il maestro non ha avuto una cattiva idea."
"Sì, è vero", aggiungeva Peter Pan.
"Stavamo su scaffali alti e nobili,
ma erano anche ricoperti di polvere.
Lui ci porta da un paese all'altro
per queste strade stupende
della Basilicata,
e soprattutto passiamo dalle mani
di un bambino a quelle di un altro bambino
che è la ragione per la quale
siamo stati scritti."
Per cui oggi, cari amici,
il Bibliomotocarro va anche a 50,
a volte supera i 50 chilometri orari,
perché io sono spinto
dall'entusiasmo dei libri
che hanno capito
che insieme dobbiamo andare
alla ricerca di nuovi lettori.
Vi sembrerà una favola,
ma è una storia vera.
Certo, mi rendo conto,
ha i contorni della favola,
ma è quello che è realmente accaduto.
I primi anni,
quando apparve il Bibliomotocarro,
in tanti mi dissero:
"Maestro", sorpresi.
"Ma cos'hai fatto?
Una cosa vecchia, superata.
Ancora con i libri!
Ma sei rimasto al mondo antico.
"Ormai i libri sono superati.
E io rispondevo:
"Guardate, il Bibliomotocarro
è un'idea post-moderna".
E mentre oggi si parla
di umanizzare la tecnologia,
io già vent'anni fa
dicevo che il Bibliomotocarro
era espressione dell'umanesimo moderno,
dove moderno, però, è aggettivo.
Cioè qualcosa che
si aggiunge al sostantivo.
Invece, che cosa è accaduto,
care amiche e cari amici,
in questi 25 anni?
C'è moderno.
Osservando i nostri comportamenti,
i comportamenti di tutti,
giovani e meno giovani, uomini e donne.
Cosa facciamo, care amiche
quando andiamo in un posto?
La prima cosa che facciamo
è vediamo se siamo connessi,
se siamo collegati.
Se c'è la rete, altrimenti andiamo
nel panico più assoluto.
Ci dà una libidine particolare
sapere che possiamo essere raggiunti
da ogni parte del mondo,
poi siamo scollegaci l'uno e l'altro
che sono affianco di banco,
marito e moglie, mamma e figli.
E allora il moderno, l'aggettivo,
ha detto: "Io devo fare l'aggiuntivo tuo
che sei nelle mie mani?
Ma io gioco una partita tutta mia.
Divento modernità."
E infatti è diventato modernità.
Ma una modernità senza umanesimo,
quella a cui stiamo assistendo,
non è nemmeno modernità,
ma un vuoto sterile, futile,
banale modernismo.
E allora,
io ho l'orgoglio e l'ambizione
di dire che con questo
mezzo umile, semplice,
avendo messo le ruote ai libri,
non solo svolgo questa azione
di promozione del libro, della lettura,
e farlo, credetemi, nei paesi
che non arrivano a mille abitanti,
dove c'è questo fenomeno continuo
dello spopolamento,
in tanti paesi dove non ci sono le scuole
e dove ci sono, sono pluriclasse.
Farlo lì, ti dà non solo un ruolo sociale,
un ruolo culturale,
ma capisci che svolgi
un ruolo che ha un valore
profondamente etico.
E dicevo, oltre a questa cosa
che è già importante,
pensate ai "Libri Bianchi",
questo laboratorio
itinerante di scrittura.
Ecco, il Bibliomotocarro
ha l'orgoglio e l'ambizione
di portare avanti il concetto
dell'umanesimo moderno,
e lo fa con l'umiltà di un mezzo,
che è il motocarro,
e con la semplicità della proposta.
Grazie.
(Applausi)